no no all right well welcome anyway
okay item two attendances have we had
any apologies uh yes we had apologies
from Council Carter
counselor Carter Jake Carter
thank you
Declarations of Interest we're all
familiar with that so if you've got any
decorations have is the minutes of the
last meeting
and those of us who are present to prove
approve those
thanks very much for the approved I'll
sign them up afterwards of the meeting
iPhone 6 questions from members of the
public were there any questions we'd now
received any
you sound very surprised when you say
that thanks anyway
so item seven is the external audit
progress report Karen are you are you
doing that from massage I will do please
okay thank you chair for external audits
the paper that we've brought for you
tonight is a progress report that
updates you uh on where we are with the
audit for the financial year ended 31st
of March 22 and also where we are with
the audit for the financial year ending
31st of March 23.
um members will of course realize that
the audit for the accounts for the
financial year ending 31st of March 22
are somewhat late in terms of being
signed off and just to kind of rehearse
that and and reasons for that in part it
is because there was a national issue in
relation to the accounting for
infrastructure assets it was a technical
matter that delayed the audit of
accounts for a number of local
authorities for the 22 Financial year
end
um we have been working with your team
now to address that and deal with the
the impact of that there is a the reason
it's taken such a long time is because
government needed to bring forward a
statutory override that allows the
council to deal with infrastructure
assets
um slightly outside of the normal course
of accounting practice if you're lying
technical that is that session
instrument didn't become
um
active until the 25th of December 22 and
the guidance from Super that allowed you
to interpret it and put it into your
accounts wasn't published until the
middle of January so
um that sort of explains really why why
some of the position
um has taken so long unfortunately that
delay has led to a subsequent issue
which is a national technical issue
emerging in relation to your accounts
which is to do with the fact that
um the pension fund at
has done the triennial revaluation work
that they need to do as part of their
normal process that has identified that
there is some movement between the uh
information that they've used based on
the 22 position and that which you had
to close down your accounts this is a
timing issue that in theory would happen
once every three years if your accounts
were normally not signed off by February
of the following Financial year
um you are in the process of dealing
with the impacts of that which is that
you've needed to get the actuary to
provide you with an updated is 19 report
it is showing
I had a quick update tonight it is
showing a material movement so you will
need to account for the new information
so my expectation is that we will be
able to come to your next audit
committee with a completed 2122 audit
and uh we will bring you at the same
time the audit plan for the 22-23 audit
because we have already commenced that
planning work even though the 2122 order
isn't finished so that's just to give
you some assurance that we will be
working to to try to catch up the the uh
the backlog if you like
um that we have
and the second part of this report
um is for your information and for your
information in the context that you were
uh effectively those responsible for the
governance of the council insofar as my
order is concerned so I bring to you
um any information that's published by
any organization that I think might be
useful to you in discharging your
responsibilities for Governors across
the council these Publications are
available to anybody and you are
encouraged obviously to share them with
other members of council who you think
may be interested or may need to know
there are a few things in there that I
would um just refer to really and the
first one is the report by the National
Audit office on tackling fraud and
corruption in government and the reason
that I bring that to your attention is
that there are
um it's as with all National Audit
office reports really it's very well
written and it will give you
um lots of information on on the sorts
of things that organizations can do to
prevent and detect fraud and Corruption
and then the other thing thing to bring
to your attention is the work that's
going on and listed in here at items
five on six around local audits so local
audit is the regime that is responsible
for the audit of local authorities
um as well as NHS bodies and some other
organizations so it's the work that I do
effectively and um those two documents
there are around some of the work that's
been done nationally to try to address
the issue that you may well be cited of
around the backlog in local government's
audits so
um they're just for information really
there's nothing that Trafford needs to
do differently or can do as a result but
may just be helpful for members to have
sight of them that's all I was going to
say but I'll take any questions
thanks any questions everybody
can I just smoke just a small punk I
noticed one in the documents
number two is tackling fraud and
corruption in government and then letter
down it's tattling phone and Corruption
against the government
is it
I can understand people want to tackle
and throw in corruption in government
I think it's probably short answering
government bodies
or as you said again against government
bodies that it probably goes both ways
okay well thanks Karen is this your
last meeting there's going to be changes
out there so we are going to change
audit Partners there is a requirements
um upon us to rotate our audit Partners
every five years
um 22 23 my sixth year if I stayed with
you because several years ago when I
worked for a different audit firm I
signed one of your audit reports because
your auditor was off sick at the time so
I stepped in to finalize your audit so
although I will only have done four with
you in this block I've also done one and
previously in the not too distant past
so in order to maintain uh proper
Independence to make sure that I don't
get too familiar with you and your
systems and processes I am going to move
on so I'll be replaced by Aleister
Newall uh he's a director in the
Manchester office who's worked with me
for some time and like me as a long
background in in local government audit
having worked for the audit commission
and and all the audit firms in between
um Alistair will pick up the 22-23 audit
it'll probably still be me at the next
audit committee because I need to close
down 21-22 but if we're bringing the
audit plan I would expect it probably to
be both of us and we'll we'll make that
break and do that hand over then so I've
probably got one more meeting with you
okay thanks very much
thanks for that Karen item eight is the
draft annual governance statement but
Alex who's going to deal with that is at
another meeting so he'll be back here
later on so we'll deal with that later
on in the meeting when he makes an
appearance so we're on to item 9 2023
Revenue budget monitoring outturn Dave
are you going to do that
yes sure thank you
um for those of you who don't know me my
name's David Grisham the head of
financial management
um what I'd normally be accompanied by
by Graham Bentley director Phil Anson
he's taken well deserved break this
weekend this week so
um he sends his apologies
um just this is the actual out turn
report the management Alton report for
uh 21 22 23.
um for those of you who've been involved
in in the past you you'll notice there's
a different format what he tried to do
is listen to some of the feedback it's
obviously ways to document there's a lot
of things to consider in these reports
we've tried to break it down into
biasized chunks
thank you
foreign
I thought the new layout was actually
much better actually but it's much more
understandable
yeah that I mean others might disagree
but I thought it was much better can I
just ask about the Travel Center is that
a temporary thing
yes it is I mean obviously with the
debenham's side was that was the big
flagship store that closed
um Marks and Spencers have moved into
there so they've been major
refurbishments so whilst they did that
refurbishment it was taken off the
rating list
um so the stores are moving around in
that one and I think we're seeing signs
of recovery in there
um the occupancy levels are going back
up to a pre-covered
um so some uh some of the bigger
Flagship stores are going in so
um it's just the timing of them coming
back online some of them have actually
Gone live they're open in for instance
last may they don't actually pay on the
race unless until they've actually
agreed the rateable value for it so
we're waiting for these to come on
knowing they're actually in there but we
can't accrue for those account for them
until they actually come on and we're
back to 80 when they come on
so there is a risk in that in terms of
obviously downtending the economy and
then the way inflation still go in
whether that'll be a recurrent risk and
so we've got a strategic risk reserve
for business rates and we know we can
dip into if we need it and it is flagged
up in terms of a a medium term strategic
risk for us the business rate take
thank you
any other questions
[Music]
so thank you for the report I'm just
looking at page 59 where you've got the
colors the red and the green and
Staffing I've got
um a surplus because if you said
stuffing vacancies and problems filling
posts it might be later on that you'll
give more information but I just
wondered what what the main issues are
there about I mean I know that
everywhere in the public sector it's
hard to fill certain posts but what it
is there any particular area where it's
particularly difficult to fill in those
posts
and I don't think in any particular area
I think we're trying to say well we're
trying to separate obviously to see the
1.8 million pound the highest figure in
that one is in within the social care
sector
um and I think again we're not we're not
alone on this one
um particularly uh recruitment to social
care uh posts and the likes of that
um we are trying to pursue a recruitment
campaign to attract people into that
side of things
um obviously looking at the terms and
conditions that the council can offer as
well that you know you can piece in the
market there with other employers so
um it's something that um HR aware of
and then they're obviously making it all
efforts they can uh to recruit to these
positions but
um I know within within my own service
it's difficult you you know you can
advertise two or three times and
um and you know it's um it's getting
younger Generations interested in
working in local government you know
when they're starting the South it was
it was quite a career and I think which
we need to start to try and
attract people but there's that many
more attractive new economy style jobs
that we were convincing with so
um as I said that that's the bulk of
that's in the social care side of things
where you compete with the health
service and the likes of that so it's it
is an issue for us
on the Scuttle right yeah
um can I ask this a section which says
about libraries and customer service
resource and it says it's something
marked for ICT upgrades plus additional
costs associated with aldringham Library
the new alteringham library could you
just explain that and can I just add by
the way that this report is is easier to
read it's really good
that's good to hear I think I have to
take that away on on what what you what
page was it it's a page 105 on the side
51 at the bottom and 109 at the top of
the
um papers 100 51
um it's
it's
draw me a lot I can I can I'll have to
go back to the teams for that one time
it's one of the Alex's sorry yeah if
it's uh
okay I can pick that up for you if
you just
so 105 51 the other one into
hello it was altering him libraries yes
I'll search for alteringham library and
I'll get back to you on that one so
tomorrow we can okay thank you I just
interested to know what the cost is uh
yeah look at this community I can find
out okay thank you
okay does that said
um I was just curious about the council
type support because it said it's lower
than
limited so that I found that quite
surprising and wonder whether people
weren't claiming it or something because
I felt like you know in the iconic
crisis it's quite strange
yes I think this is against budget so
when we we set the budget
um
on anticipation that council tax support
levels uh they are they're going to be
slightly higher than they were
um obviously the the schemes the schemes
sat within the parameters on it so it's
it's
I think
um
the principle obviously people apply for
it Mrs Sonic but you know it's it's nice
well it's one respect it's nice to see
that we weren't having to you know
support many people as much as we
thought we were but these are always
against compared with what we budgeted
for
um so we had actually anticipated there
would be an increase in it it's not
transpired that side of things so it's
the same during covid and lockdown I
think obviously had to benefit from
furlough helped out with the cash in the
economy so people weren't necessarily
needing to apply for it so
um you know and I think with employment
rate still fairly buoyant
um even though the cost of living
increases eating into disposable income
um it's obviously one of the certain
conditions that hasn't actually
transpired it was needed in that tax
then
okay thank you I'm new to this so I need
to get my head around over yeah I was
quite it's it's good that you know you
obviously gave a much generous amount
for it than you thought there would be
but it would still concern me a bit if
people if there were people not claiming
but it's probably not the case thank you
okay
Council Jerome and then councilor
thanks chair
um I suppose over the next year savings
are going to be crucial and in the
Savings Program the very last entry for
the digital strategy it's gone from red
to Amber but in the very last sentence
in in the last column it says savings
yet to be identified and I take it the
digital strategy will be quite crucial
to as part of the Savings Program
yes it is I mean the savings program
that we put in and and here it was it
was a a broad theme that well if we
introduce technology and I think at the
time it was introduced it was we'll
introduce it there the Power Platform
that we've done for Microsoft which was
basically analyzing workflow and and
using voluntary groups within the
council just to try out the technology
so what what's each process from
um business standard business process
how many people get involved and it was
a time taken and some of this technology
that we've got with this package to say
can we can we streamline these things so
that work it started to reach to a stage
where they've got pilots in place now to
say right we can potentially
um try this concept in these areas we're
used to work in it many many years ago
it's it's it's sometimes I think
that the um Ambitions can sometimes
overtake the actual reality of the
things what they take time to deliver
because it's always slithers of people's
jobs I think all of a sudden you can
then start to amalgamate it after a
period of time and say okay that's a few
processes here and here and here there's
the same people in that group we can
start to look at reconfiguring it and
it's always difficult when you're
looking at digital savings on that one
because they're all piecemeal but I
think the principle is strategically is
going to deliver but it's going to take
time with hindsight once you've applied
it here and now you can start using that
model that's that's a principle at it so
that first year saving of a hundred
thousand then thinking was hundred
thousand it was still up in the air at
the year end we've still got we've got
another this concept saving as well in
The Current financial year and to be
honest I think that will also be one of
those things that starts saying at what
point do actually Chris Slauson realize
it
um as I say we we are we are working
through this strategy and I think all of
a sudden it'll come together and it's
all right okay we can see some tangible
benefits from it
really
um I just wanted to remark on the fact
that we did come in with a balance at
the the end of it that we're actually
above water I look at our woking and
thurrock and
um you know other councils we never used
to hear of councils going bust what we
do now
um
and badly bust
um in terms of thorac and woking noted
um they're massive that they is going to
take years for those to recover
so I think um you know well done on that
my last niggle is can we can we stick to
the page numbers of the report rather
than the overall take the lowest carbon
denominator the page number of the the
individual report is on everybody's page
sometimes I haven't got the um the
bigger document page numbers and it's
taken me a while to catch up with where
you were I'm looking for colors that
aren't there across both both sides of
that one I was using my page reports on
the actual report and the comments came
out can we use the actual public
information about page report so it's a
mixed bag so I think I think quoting
both can sound confusing but I don't
think that there's any way around it
other than that one
huh
because Germany come back
yeah there was just one other question I
just wanted to quickly ask and ask about
the nine-day Fortnight in the Savings
Program I take it that's people working
five days one week and four the next
and was that offered to all staff and
how many people yeah it's a it's a mixed
bag it is um yeah it's generally one day
and every Fortnight that you would say
have not been paid obviously you reduce
your pay
um take-up's been been mixed on that one
there's been a few that want to do it I
think with obviously with the flexi time
system the council operates and the bank
leave scheme this disease or the various
options within within the package nice
of that and again it's a point that that
principle in terms of Staff retention
and recruitment these are the type of
things that aren't just a savings but
also somebody that we can attract staff
by offering these these pack of these
flexible working Arrangements but uh but
the nandy Fortnight they say there's
been
minus a cup of it enough to think
there's something in is as in a saving
so that's the principle of it
are you aware that
um South Cambridgeshire have moved to a
four day week but still on the same pay
but it is meant to produce yeah increase
productivity and yeah self-retention and
attracting stuff yeah it's been
discussed as a principle I think it's uh
it's quite obviously groundbreaking as
as a concept and uh
um I think there's a number of private
sector companies have also done it as
well so it's in the mix there and I
think obviously with this Stafford
retention recruitment issue these are
all the things that you've got to start
on realistically looking at
yeah
thanks so much I've seen it and oh sorry
thank you chair
um I just ask again I'd say Well done on
the at a glance section I thought it
made a real difference being able to
just lift off the figures the main ones
so a bunch of improvement there
um can I also ask because
you did end up with a good result and
you've been able to put quite a few
um increase in reserves aside and also
there's a certain increase in funding in
some of the problem areas that we've
been having do you feel more comfortable
going forward for for next year
obviously I know there'll be some more
unknowns and there'll be other issues we
face but I did see a few areas where the
increases should hopefully support you a
bit more going forward yeah I think so I
think the thing on the funding side of
it we've done well in terms of the
business rates and I think the message
in there you know 10 like a million
pound a lot of that's one off we've
looked at the amount of money we set
aside historically for provision for
appeals Provisions haven't they weren't
required so we've really said right
let's try and be realistic release those
so the one-offs no I think that's that
that's the key thing
um Staffing savings again they're
one-offs they shouldn't happen it was a
recurring basis on that so there's a few
pockets in there
um like early retirement pension and
announcements from people who retire in
the 80s and 90s obviously they're
diminishing over time possibility to
release those but not there's not a lot
of significant recurrent items in that
one and then with inflation obviously
being as high as it says and also not
dropping at the speed with the today's
announcements 8.7
we we know that the likes of the pay
award for The Current financial year is
probably going to be higher than some of
the figures we're already discussing I
think one percent with million is nine
hundred thousand pounds for extra one
percent so those are the things that
we're still wary about uh the budget
plans for the current Financial year the
what's ones would be developing for this
next financial year there's still a
significant Gap in there so we're not
out of the woods by any means and and I
think you know it's our national level
the money in the system is probably not
enough to cater for all the demand we're
getting in there so
um we still are sleepless nights
yeah
okay that's it thanks thank you very
much David for that I can see Alex has
now appeared so are you ready to do uh
item eight which is the uh draft annual
government statement
thank you Chad
um yes so this is the draft annual
governance statement and you get it
every year as the name would suggest
um
and it just looks at the governance
framework
um split into three parts first part is
looking at
um work that's been done in the year to
meet uh across the framework to meet the
standards uh the second part is a review
of how the council's done against its
significant governance issues identified
in the previous
um annual governance statement and the
third part is
um outlining the significant government
governance issues for the next financial
year
um in the executive summary
um this time around have highlighted
that traffic search there's been a lot
of change in leadership nationally with
the queen having passed and that being
has moved on to the
um
was it coronation of King Charles III
um in Trafford we've seen a change of
leadership from Council Weston who's now
an MP uh to councilor Tom Ross
um and within the Health Organization
we've seen the dissolution of ccgs and
the creation of uh integrated care
boards with the chief executive Sarah
Dodd now being the place based lead for
Trafford which should hopefully see a
lot more cross working between uh with
our Partners in Health
um and then other than that highlighted
the large amount of work that as
contribution in uh The Ledger
um services within Trafford uh the
excellent work of the finance team in
dealing with the stresses and strains of
the uh rise of inflation over the course
of the year and the
uh offside report which showed that uh
Trafford was no longer um in special
measures and they'd got a result of
requires Improvement
and so yeah if anyone has any questions
I'm happy to take them
um yeah you talk about covid and it kind
of is looking as if it's going down
but
um
is there any kind of contingency plans
within there because
at
I can't remember when they were but we
did have
um the potential for two pandemics MERS
and Son became pandemic it's not a
question if
there's going to be another pandemic
it's when it's going to be another
pandemic and I have the council got a
sufficient
a sufficient eye on the possibility of
this occurring
um
[Music]
I think one of the outcomes of the last
pandemic is that it is increased the
size of the public health Team within
Trafford so they're much better
positioned to um
identify any future risks and to
mitigate anything that comes along
within the update that's been provided
around
um covid which was
highlighted as a significant risk in
last year's AGS it does kind of have a
caveat at the bottom where it's saying
that currently the risk is very low so
it's moved down on the Strategic risk
register so I don't know if it's
um it's not in one of the top risks
anymore so it's not on next year's
annual governance statement but it does
say that if a new variant came along
then this situation could change very
quickly
um but due to Trafford not having any
um
bring fenced funding Fork overt anymore
then unfortunately it's a position that
Trafford is unable to combat directly
although I say the size of the team
within Trafford has increased and um
they are
in a much stronger position I think than
they were pre-covered
after Jerome
um thanks Joe thanks for the report it's
a very easy to read through
um I was just wondering on the Amy
contract The Seven Year review is
absolutely crucial for the Improvement
and operating of that contract so it
does say that the viewers can be
completed by summer 2023 do you know if
that's on track
uh yes that is on track um the uh Amy
seven year review is going to the
scrutiny committee on the 12th of July
and and that's before it goes to the
executive on the 24th of July I believe
okay thanks anybody else
well thanks Alex can we note the report
thank you
we move on now to item
item item 10 which is the zip for uh
external assessment of internal audit
Market
thank you chair uh and Mark Foster audit
Insurance manager I am responsible for
the internal audit function
um so this this report basically is in
effect an audit of internal audit um we
had
internal audit sections
um in local government are required to
be assessed externally at least every
five years so we were last reviewed in
2018 so we would do this year
um and in agreement with the Director of
Finance and also
um the audit committee chair we agreed
that sit for wouldn't take that
assessment there are various providers
sit for as a a key standard Setter
um seen The Logical Choice
um as part of the process we had to
provide evidence to sit for across a
whole number of areas of our our work
um and also as part of the process they
undertook a number of interviews with
officers members
um the external auditor and they also
conducted a survey as well of officers
and some members as well and and that's
reflected in the report
um so the sort of areas that include
there's quite a wide number of areas
that things like our audit procedures
and the way we set out responsibilities
in the team training Arrangements
um are planning our delivery of audits
and our reportings a whole number of
areas looked at
um and in the report an apologies
because I've made notes of the larger
number but I'll let I'll go with the go
with the other number
um in section 10 of the report on page
um there are three possible opinion
levels that could be given in the
assessment these being generally
conforms partially conforms and does not
conform
um in like a green Amber and red and the
overall headline for us that we we do
generally conform uh which is the
highest of the of the three opinions we
could get
um
in terms of the report sections four and
five then go through detail of why they
came to that that conclusion
um and you can see all the different
subheadings showing uh the green
generally conforms
so there were no actual formal
recommendations for us in terms of
adherence to standards
um but what it was it was a useful
exercise in terms of there was like an
advisory element to the work as well uh
and sit for came up with a number of
advisory points that are included in the
action plan at the end for us to
consider going forward and I've
completed a management response to that
action plan
um and some of the detail is in terms of
reflected in in future reporting uh and
indeed the annual head of internal audit
report
um on the agenda does pick up on a
couple of the items in the action plan
um another issue is is around capacity
in the team and it's an issue we picked
up on earlier around recruitment
um and so it is an area where we're
looking at over the over the coming 12
months
um so we were quite happy we were happy
with the process and happy with the with
the advisory points that came out and in
terms of the action plan it's something
I can continue to to update the
committee on
down the line in future meetings
thanks Mark any questions about that
no thanks very much thank you so we'll
move on to item 11 which is your Mark's
annual head of uh internal audit report
so in terms in terms of the the public
sector audit standards there is a
requirement to produce an annual report
which uh which sets out our work in
internal audit for for the previous year
um and also a key element of that report
is to provide an opinion on the standard
of controls in place so covering
internal control risk management
governance
um and also that opinion is reflected in
the annual governance statement uh which
which Alex went through
um
our audit work is conducted in
accordance with what we call an internal
audit Charter and that was it that was
approved that the uh the last meeting in
March and it sets out the roles and
responsibilities of internal audit
um
in terms of our overall opinion in the
report uh where they've been completed
during the year is derived from our
individual audits we've gone
um follow-up of previous audit work and
also from other sources of assurance uh
that we've that we've gathered and the
overall headline in terms of the opinion
that would provide a reasonable level of
assurance that the control of
environments operates into a
satisfactory standard
um a section 2.2 of the report sets out
some of the factors
uh determining that overall opinion
talking about individual audit opinions
we've given on particular audit reviews
um just like sit for had for for on the
audit of internal or we have a number of
different opinion levels we'd give
um and ranging from substantial
Assurance to no assurance and and the
majority of opinions were either
substantial or reasonable where we've
given reasonable the the most likely
quite a few areas for some improvement
but overall finding reasonable Assurance
is in place and there was one final
report issued during the year where a
lower uh opinion level was given at
limited assurance and that related to
one of the school pieces of work but we
have actually just undertaken a
follow-up review in the last few weeks
and and we've noted good improvements in
in that school so we'll be reporting on
that in the next in the next uh update I
give at the next meeting
um
just in terms of the table lamp page 10
of the report which summarizes the
number of uh opinion levels we've given
different different Audits and you can
see
um as well as substantial and reasonable
Assurance levels there was also a number
of Grant checks completed through the
year where in turnlord it's been
required by government to to undertake
checks and provide Assurance so again
that adds to the overall picture and the
Assurance level we've given
um during 223 there was regular report
into the committee in our quarterly
update so there shouldn't be surprises
in the annual report in a sense we've
picked up a lot of the issues within
those costly updates uh but there's also
an update for the final quarter of the
year in this report uh on page 29 which
which draws out a number of recent
audits we've completed which includes
business continuity uh contract
monitoring around way so Services those
nodes to registrar service and also
adaptations
um
in the appendices that those listings of
work completed for the year so in
appendix B it summarizes that's starting
page 32 summarizes the uh the different
categories of audit work and appendix C
then less individual audit reports that
we've issued or we're planning to
complete in the coming months
um
there is also a section if you go on
Section 3.9 going back to page 11 uh
just acknowledging that there's work
completed that doesn't involve issuing
audit reports as such though the
supports are different processes uh the
annual governance statement working with
Alex and his team providing some
guidance and support around that the
Strategic risk register work that will
cover in a separate item and we've also
provided various guidance uh guidance to
schools for instance around I.T security
and governance some have issued guidance
report on that
so I won't cover each of the sections in
terms of the different categories of
work in in detail but it's in section
four
it covers various areas like the
financial systems work we've done
counter fraud risk management I.T audits
number of different service Audits and
schools
um within all these pieces of work where
we've made recommendations
um we asked for management responses in
terms of agreement to the
recommendations made and we did find a
positive response during the year with
with all the the the formal
recommendations made being accepted
during the year
we've also done some follow-up work
um on particularly on audits we've done
in the previous year to look how how
well action plans were progressing
um and that's a combination of us doing
checks and audit as part of a further
Audits and also getting updates from
management
um on progress being made
um so there is um page 25 a chart that
shows
um broken down between recommendations
that have been implemented and those
that have either been implanted in part
or in progress and also those that
haven't been and for overall there's
taking the the figures as 92 percent
have either been implemented or in
progress of being implemented with which
was a positive thing for us to see when
we're doing follow-up work
um
just in terms of our overall performance
against the plan we'd set ourselves a
target of 30 audit assignments during
the year comprising the the audit
reports advisory work and Grant uh
sign-offs and in total we just about
achieved that the 31 were produced
um we did spend a bit less time than
we'd originally planned to do in terms
of resources but we did use a
contingency time uh vacant post there so
we've used contingency time to offset
that to some degree and there were also
a number of audits at the request of
services that we'd agreed to reschedule
anyway into the coming year so we were
able then to to undertake all our areas
of priority work during the year
uh and then finally the report just
picks up on on the item covered before
around the sit for uh standards
assessment and just summarizes the the
findings the findings from that
um we'll continue to give updates on the
work each quarter so in the September
meeting I'll give an update on April to
June work but happy to take any
questions on this report Mark any
questions comes accordingly
um yeah uh on the Waste Services
um bought it
can I just make sure that I'm talking I
am understanding it right this is a
normal refuse collection is it or is it
a different yeah
[Music]
yeah
I mean one one of the um issues that
I've always had well in
compared to who's say 15 years ago we
used to have lots and lots of
performance indicators right across the
piece in every area of council business
they don't seem to exist anymore to the
same extent in terms of uh National
setting and you know and and what have
you so
judging the waste
performance is is very much uh a a
subjective view of waste and it's
largely it seems to me but in terms of
what I pick up it seems to be largely
monitoring bionecdotes in terms of waste
um you know if we've had a lot of
complaints or if we we've gone gone
fewer
few weeks without complaints and and I
don't I I I I really struggled to see
how we're monitoring that to the to a
proper
objective standard I mean the contract
was very weak when it was first
implemented and uh a lot of the
monitoring was self-monitoring by Amy
and we've moved a little bit away from
that I don't think we're anywhere near
where I would like us to be in terms of
monitoring and so I'm wondering when it
comes to auditing
how we can objectively audit when we
haven't
got those data sets that we really need
to be able to monitor this there
certainly is as part of the review I
know there were there were a number of
performance indicators in place and that
were being reported against and I know
there was validation
by the council as well sample checks of
of the data that's been provided so I
know it's there could perhaps get hold
of that information
yes because I've never seen it published
foreign
okay so I'm new to this committee so I'm
not quite sure how the work plans are
decided so
um that might be part of my question how
do we decide the work plan for the
committee because I know on previous
committees I've sat on there's been
suggestions for work plans and the
councilors have decided what the
priorities are for that committee for
the year
but I want to just go to Quest to page
15 which is 167
and it's paragraph
for two four that one
yeah
because this seemed quite significant to
me this particular paragraph
because it talks about the um
governance issues and you referred to
Alex's report earlier on
um that did have a question for Alex but
I just didn't get my hand up in time is
he gone now
yeah so I have to ask you the question
um and my question is it says here
um what the significant
information governance issues are and it
talks about one traffic partnership
addressing the climate change emergency
managing increased demand for school
places developments in government
support developing etc etc
and in Alex's report on page 24 talks
about the climate change emergency this
one talks about addressing the climate
change crisis
so my question is to me that seems like
a significant piece of work that ought
to be happening because the climate
change emergency is upon us we all know
it's upon us it's getting worse as the
report States it impacts on every single
area wide-ranging cross-cutting and
character was quoting Alex's report
so I'm wondering how do me as a
counselor get on the agenda to request
some kind of audit on our response to
the climate change emergency the
um
our internal audit plan comes here every
march to visit came in March for the
23-4 we did actually agree with the
place director to include an item in the
plan around the climate emergency
um I know the the introducing Staffing
within the service around it
um
uh the new head of climate change has
been established yes so we we have we
haven't sort of defined exactly what we
do but we we have agreed in the final
quarter that this current year that in
the internal audit plan we would do some
work look at looking at reviewing what
what's happening around the council so
the response to that so that it is
included in the internal audit plan but
I haven't got anything sort of further
at the moment on what what we plan to do
on it so so I guess with I can see in
the report earlier on it said the
um new head of climate change has been
established and will be recruited early
23 24. that seems like quite a long way
ahead if you're talking about 24 or is
that just
like um The Current financial year
um
is everything waiting upon that
appointment then before there's any kind
of
solid information on that
um well just from internal audits point
of view we were aware though they were
looking at appointing and we agreed
based on whatever body of work was done
that we'd be an opportunity later in the
year for us to us to have a look at
development so provisionally we'd kind
of put something in for quarter four
um but there will be it's on the
Strategic risk register as well so the
committee would get updates through the
year as well in terms of any
developments on that
so as a counselor am I in a position on
this committee to kind of request some
kind of report on audits around our
response to the climate change emergency
is that something I can request as I
would do on other committees and and how
would that work if I wish to put that
through
um we would get requests sometimes for
instance I'll sit on the Strategic risk
item where it's covering those you know
that as one example where it might be if
the committee wants more information on
it so in the past an officer may have
come to a future committee meeting and
provided an update on developments or
provided a briefing so yeah this is
something that we when we're talking
about the uh that one of the later items
the committee's work program we could
so so through the chair can I perhaps
make that request
and to be raised at the appropriate time
and to be voted on if you require it to
be voted on
yeah like Mark said iPhone 14 is a work
program so that's the appropriate place
I think really to include it in that and
maybe it when even well when the new
officers appointed and got his feet
under his or her feet under the table a
bit they can come and give us a update
can't they on
they're doing because we do from time to
time have people come together a talk
about activities that they're
undertaking you know officers so I think
that would be appropriate obviously once
they've uh you know been here a bit that
we can come and ask them to give a
report on that
sorry yeah
thank you I just wanted to add to that
that I I I found out the other night on
some training there's some work being
done on resilience and I'd like to
include that on that as well because
they said they've just started to look
at it but you know we need to be
preparing now for this risk and
yes I would like to that to be included
as well
thank you
okay is that that's it
very much so now we're going to the the
Strategic risk register which is
relevant to what we've just been talking
about really
okay so we we provide updates um through
the uh to the committee on the Strategic
risk register
um this latest update was gathered with
information
basically around the end of May uh some
of it in the early June
um and that's been provided by which is
just it's not an internal audit report
it it's uh based on updates provided by
CLT and relevant Services
um and and they provide updates which
which we collate
um there are currently 16 strategic
risks on the register that have been
reported on
um at previous committee meetings
um
each risk is covered uh summary on in
section three there's a table where uh
freeze of the 16 rests their details on
action being taken uh to address it and
also where there's particular future
plans and developments that's indicated
as well
um
sorry yeah
so page 191
is the start of the Strategic risk
report
Pages at the side rather at the bottom
well I don't know
directory
I've got different patients
it starts off with you for those clothes
it's two pages down from that one that
you've got there
just after the internal audit report
it's the one with red on it
yeah
okay
um so just
um flag in really key changes uh the
committee received the our previous
report in March and just flagging
changes since then uh there was one
change in Risk score and that relates to
risk number 14 which is set out in more
detail on page 215 or 25.
um and that was around the uh
disruption around covid-19 and winter
pressures and the overall covid-19 risk
has been on the register obviously for
for three years
um the score has gone now to a low risk
eight
um so details of this risk that they'll
be subject to further review regards the
future inclusion of the risk and how
that that might be set out
um but there are also updates on each of
the others in the register
um
so happy to take any any uh any
questions I could or feed you know
follow up any queries uh if you have any
on those individual uh
um updates and of course as we said
before if there was a particular
um
desire to have more detail on it we we
could look at fracturing into the work
program any of those any of those areas
let's mark any questions to mark
Jerome
thanks one of the
risks identified is uh the ability of
the joint venture partner
to deliver
required standards
obviously that's how you make
we're just coming I mean councilor
um
Julian
mentioned this earlier in in terms of
The Seven Year review and I had to look
at the seven year review it should have
been done two years ago should have been
done 12 months before the seven years
were up we're now into year eight so it
should have been done we struggled to
get that done on time we're coming you
know we're now moving over the the brow
of the Hill towards the end of the
contract
we're into the second half of the
um
I don't see it as a risk identified that
we get that contract
sorted in time and I think it will be a
growing risk if we struggle to get it
done it halfway where you should be
earlier at some point we're going to
have to let that contract again
and
if it
it's it's certainly not year 15 that we
look at we have to give the decision
well before then
I think it's 12 months before the end of
the contract we have to decide whether
we're we're doing it and I worry with
the slippage on these whether these are
um
we can adhere to this and we'll end up
with um
having to take a contract that isn't
what we want because we haven't done the
due work and what have you so I I looked
through and I looked for something on
that and I'm thinking blamey this is
coming around the hill and it is quite
tricky this you know the the amount of
work to change from one contractor to
another will be huge and I I just want
to make sure that we're prepared for
that and uh monitoring that risk
and that is certainly be something that
will continue to be monitored through
these updates so you hopefully will see
the progress yeah
um it's about the Freedom of Information
requests that
um we get and I notice it went down in
quarter four
um and I understand that you've got
different
uh mechanisms for the children the place
in children's Social Service
directorates doing their own but
wouldn't it be are you are you are you I
know you're in talks but is there um
a mechanism for getting everything
centrally because
um getting freedom of the information
requests and inquiries
so if it's a monitoring thing isn't it
um so that you can pick up on particular
issues
[Music]
I know um
around information governance team and
the the service review and they're
looking at all those different processes
so in terms of and that's one thing I've
identified not sure exactly what the
conclusions are
um how they you know around this
some things the fois some being outside
of the main Central function so it's
something I can take
well yeah because I do think it's it's
especially if we're not answering the
questions I'll given the information to
the public on time and it's actually not
improving I mean at all and it's not
even reaching out 95 Target
okay
okay anything else just looks good
yeah it's just about the school
placements um the risk I think that we
could have some more detail on that one
as well because the new you know all the
housing developments that are being
introduced into Stratford is concerning
and the amount of children having to
travel to school and how that affects
air quality and
costs it's it's kind of quite scary
isn't it so if you could have some more
information on that
be um in terms of of what they do
continuing to do to address it I know
it was a roughy
and yeah that anticipating my question
there that's good I was looking at the
actions for the school places and it's
still a
20 the the risk here for likelihood for
impact five so
if all those actions are taken
is the risks still be or if all the
actions are taken would that bring that
risk of the school places down
yeah I mean there's certainly potential
um you would expect the score to be
reviewed in light of
actions being taken each time
um I suppose it would depend on the how
the demand was going as well if that was
being met and there was a bit more
capacity
um but that was something we'd expect
the service to keep under review and
monitor the risk level as a result of
their actions so
because I've not been on this committee
I do know that school places as your
other counselor highlighted has been an
issue
for the boroughs particularly in the
South for quite a long time has it been
that high level or is that a rescore has
increased over the last however many
years it's been on yeah in the last
couple of years that the score has gone
up so 20 is like is that the peak score
we've been at
I think that's the highest that that
risk has been at yeah
and all the mitigation actions have they
been put in as a result of it being high
risk or were they in place anyway well
there are a number of
a small read scene process that they got
in place but I know there's always
additional measures are taken as a
result of the increased demand so uh
each of these strategic risk updates
have been new things been added in terms
of measures of you know over the last
couple of years that they've been taking
yeah did I say Council Brophy are you
looking are you looking for something
else or
no I thought to encourage you to them
okay yeah yeah okay anybody else
counselor Joe yeah thanks Joe
um I was just looking at the climate
change emergency risk obviously it's 20s
it's high which is exactly right
um and it in the first paragraph it does
talk about the the types of risks that
we might be facing such as extreme
weather events but then if it look you
look at the recent actions and further
actions they're all about decarbonizing
um rather than addressing the risks that
we might be facing so only last week
Altrincham Town Center was flooded very
very quickly and very dramatically with
the number of shops having to close down
uh sellers being flooded Etc but there's
nothing here that really
says how we're trying to mitigate that
risk or deal with that risk even if we
do our decarbonization program in
Trafford we are still relying on the
rest of the world to do their
decarbonization so
our program doesn't
necessarily reduce the risks but it
doesn't seem that anywhere here I'll
feed that back in terms of level of
detail yeah and I know that you know
we've got a new design code which does
deal with sustainable Urban drainage Etc
so there are things happening but maybe
um within this report it should be
highlighting some of those things
because you know in some of the flooding
events that we're experiencing really
are quite dramatic
okay thanks
that I I agree with councilor on this in
in that it's also it's not just the
flooding it's all the other risks as
well around people kind of
being overheated and
I do think this is quite um a kind of
sparse response in terms of
um addressing the issues it just it's
just bullet points it doesn't give any
um
kind of plan for how the actual
emergency and the issues
the Council of your own mentioned it
doesn't have anything there that says
how we're going to deal with the
flooding he doesn't have anything about
how we're going to deal with the fact
we're going to have a lot of people who
are sort of overheated and suffering
poor health as a result of overheating
and all when we had the 37 degrees last
summer
that was if you like a
it was thought to be like an unusual
event but actually that's what we're
looking to in the future so it's like
looking at that really high temperature
zone we had last year and thinking
what do we need to put in to make sure
that people in Trafford have got some
kind of resilience and protection to
those situations as you can see perhaps
of feedback if there's referencing to
things being done that isn't maybe has
been done but isn't reflected on
feedback feedback
excellent
I yeah and yeah sorry just to add as
well that I mean I think as mentioned I
don't know if it was in this report but
somewhere else was mentioned just about
cold weather so that was the only issue
and that was I found that quite shocking
because there's so much more to it than
that so yeah so I would just like to
reinforce what you said if we can get
some more discussion on there that would
be great thank you
I thought you're going to mention you
did some work at the GM level about
flooding did you and
I think you know it's greater risk of
surface water drainage than other kinds
of flooding and how we need to you know
make sure we've got impermeable surfaces
and
stop artificial grass and things like
that so it's quite interesting
okay that is well finished thank you
so uh
I'm looking somewhere October 2013
aren't we it's the animal an annual
report
which is uh the report that goes under
my name and Council Elijah's name to
committee to council is it September
when it goes to council there is
um there is one in July July yeah
which is yeah
so if anybody wants to ask me any
questions on that it's really about what
we've done in the last last year
okay thanks very much
an item uh 14 is the work program which
is
Monk
um so
the report sets out the proposed work
program for the for the rest of the year
um against each of the the plan meetings
um is there as well to make sure the
committee meets his basic
responsibilities
um including things like in respect of
um review approval of the accounts and
the annual governance statement
um but it is as always a very flexible
plan and get cemented Through The Years
needed and there's new issues arise or
if things have to be rescheduled
um it also highlights
um elements of training and briefing
sessions so as part of different items
that come likes of the budget monitor
reports and treasury management reports
and all the the planning to do some
detailed updates alongside that
briefings to help you know part of sort
of members understanding training
um
so we've listed a few in there
um this work programs included with the
agenda each each meeting so you'll be
able to see any changes and and you know
if you want to recommend any updates to
that as we as we go through the year and
um so discuss through through the chair
as well if there's any any items you you
wish to uh to add in
um so just asking the committee to
agreed agree the program and if there's
anything else um wish to add in at this
stage
[Music]
okay
yeah
this is just an
assistant
um being used as committee so these
um work plans they're all about sort of
things that are on the risk register I
suppose so can we add the two items we
discussed earlier on the agenda one
being
schools resilience and the
Pace there's not enough places for
schools and the other one being the
climate change emergency response so
those two things that we can add on to
the work plan yeah with it within the um
the risk management strategic risks
column there there's there was we've
allowed for gaps if you like first
because this is just the general report
you've had to obviously looking at
individual areas
just the other thing is to make sure
that we don't clash with something that
might be done by
um the scrutiny committees because I can
see some work programs that could be fed
into those two committees so that we're
not
um duplicating stuff that's been doing
elsewhere
so
Mark can I check can I just come in on
the back of that because I think the
important thing is to remember in that
context the function of this committee
so you've got a responsibility here to
make sure that risks are being managed
through the council and it seems to me
to be absolutely right that you would
pick a couple of risks that are in the
corporate risk register and do a little
bit of a deep dive into them to
understand better what happens but you
need to come at it from the context of
not what the council is doing about the
climate change emergency but how the
council is managing that risk so you're
asking for Assurance about the actions
that are being taken to manage the risk
you're not trying to get into is the
council doing the right thing to in
respect to the climate emergency if that
makes sense and I think that's how you
steer clear of tripping over what
scrutiny committees might be doing
so you're you're about the process of
managing the risk not not the detail of
of the council's response if other
council's activities if that makes sense
absolutely I was just going to ask about
when's the training like to start
because I really want some training so I
get what I'm doing supposed to be doing
thank you
and I think you're absolutely right what
what you need to be clear about is that
there is a process in place for managing
those risks what you're not doing
um and perhaps I didn't explain it very
well but what you're not doing is
getting into the detail of what those
actions are you just need assurance that
somebody is responsible for it they're
doing something about it and they can
tell you what they're doing about it
um but you're not challenging the what
you're challenging that is it being done
and who whereabouts in the council is it
being reported so which members know
what's going on there which offices are
in charge of it how often are they
refreshing it
um and you know and then that that stand
back question about does all this look
very sensible because what you've got
here doesn't but underneath this will be
much more detail about what the council
is doing about exactly the things that
you've mentioned it's just about how you
get assurance that that exists
that's probably a case of bringing
officers into the room yeah with yeah
so would that cover things like how
aware are they of the risks kind of
thing as well and
and are they doing enough to
deal with those risks yes
thanks Joe I just wanted to ask about
the work program
I'll take it we'd have to decide it
tonight if we did want to get something
onto the work program say in the next
few weeks have we got time to kind of do
some more reading look into a bit more
it's very it's a very fluid program in
the sense each each meeting or in
between meetings we can we can amend it
and add things to it as needed yeah it's
an indication
it it sets out some of the things we
know we want we need to do and
um that it leaves a room for other
things to be added yeah
okay that's a useful discussion
uh all right add some 15 urgent business
I'm not aware of any business no no
out of 15 there's nothing uh private so
we're not screwing anybody
so that's the uh the end of the meeting
thanks everybody for their attendance